but i never like expected anything and
it's like okay yeah the things come
which is nice
but i still believe that as as i get
older
i'm always gonna have to make [ __ ]
myself record my own albums
i could you know record my own special
like you don't have to wait
for you know that you can make [ __ ]
happen you can produce your own shows
and like be a nice person and not [ __ ]
on anyone while you do it
all right hot breath averse welcome back
to hot breath
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros i'm your host
comedian joel byers and today we have a
very
special guest by request
might i add you from a member of this
community
he actually saw her in a zoom show and
was like this is one of the funniest
comics i've ever seen we've got to have
her on the show
and now without further ado she is on
the show
the one the only vanessa gonzalez
everyone give it up for vanessa
hello
it is i'm doing a an applause sound
effect for you right now
so welcome thank you for uh doing this
first off it's so great to have you on
the show
yeah thanks for having me that's so nice
to hear you know i've been doing these
zoom shows
and i'm like i don't know what people
are the most
[Music]
it's very nice to be like oh someone
liked it
is is that what you've been doing with
your time mostly
yeah i mean uh i was doing comedy
full-time and you know hitting the road
and all
and then this hit and i was like oh no
and at first like in march i was like
i'm not gonna do zoom shows
but it's like that's all we got now so
we
i i had to adapt and and figure it out
though
i'm glad it's kind of working yeah
that's great
how often are you doing them because
there is some sort there is some
questions
some of like are they even worth doing
and things like that
but i like what's been your experience
with them
well luckily i've been able to do like
one or two a week um
yeah of like stand-up quote-unquote
stand-up
even though i'm sitting in my pajamas in
my house
um but yeah it's been interesting you
know sometimes there's just like
12 people in the zoom and i've done
where there's
i've done some where there's like more
people so
it's been it's been nice when like
people are unmuted and you actually hear
laughs again that's
i think that's what i miss most is
hearing people
laugh you know that's what fuels
us oh and that energy
i think that's what i miss is like that
i mean the high from it there's no
i mean it's a threat exactly yeah
and i i'm working on like i'm making the
most of it by really like
building this facebook group and really
focusing on the podcast and
building the community and connecting
with comics
but it is like it is still though the
stage it's
it's just like i know there's nothing
yeah
we all we're all addicts we all have
problems
um but yeah it's it's not the same it's
not the same
and i find myself like because i'm in
austin right now
and i see that like in new york and la
they're starting to do like outside
shows which seems
nice and safe for people um
but in austin it's just too damn hot
like even at night even like
well it's like 9 00 p.m and it's 98
degrees like nobody wants to be sitting
outside
so hopefully we can like figure out
something like that here in austin but
in a safe way um but yeah
i definitely miss the the thrill of
of making a group of people laugh in
front of you
yeah yeah because you actually you
started comedy in austin right
yeah i started here i i was here for
about 10 years and i moved to l.a
and i was in la for two years you know
doing the grind
and then what is that grind though wait
tell us tell us that grind because
there's a lot of
newer comics that are members of this
group
that just oh the glitz and glamour of
l.a
or like moving to new york and i'm in it
you know but like what is
we had sean patton on here who broke
down the grind of new york comedy
like i've never heard just the brutal
reality of it like what is the grind
oh well yeah i mean in new york i'm sure
it's different but i i mean my grind
in la was i was able to do
i kept hearing like you know it's hard
to get shows in la but luckily
i was able to be you know have shows
pretty regularly
at least one a week
you know which was like pretty good for
la of like a book show
uh and then you have like your open mics
and things like that but
um yeah book shows are are harder to get
more consistent
uh in la i think the most i went without
doing a show in la was like two weeks
and that was like uh oh my gosh i need
to be on a show
um so yeah doing that going on the road
luckily i you know i would i i'm
i love austin and the club here would
always like give me time if i wanted to
work out an hour that's the hard thing
too when you're grinding in la
you're not going to get more than 10
minutes you know if you're
eight minutes um so it's like hard to
kind of work on a longer
set in la because you just get
like five seven eight minutes at a time
uh so luckily whenever i needed to work
on longer sets i'd come home to austin
they'd let me headline here and things
like that so
yeah and doing it 10 years in austin i
think is uh
probably beneficial in terms of just
figuring out how to do
comedy before you move to l.a
yeah i was talking with someone recently
like i i know so many people that
start in la and i'm just like damn
that's
i can't imagine it seems really hard to
start
there but people do it and and [ __ ]
like those
the the people i know that started in la
are like
the hardest like grinders
in the grind you know um but i was
yeah i i think i'm lucky that i was able
to start in austin
there's such a like tight community here
with stand-up i did
uh improv and sketch too so i kind of
like was able to do everything and
and it was nice to kind of like you know
uh kind of get decent before i went to
la you know yeah and what what was that
decision what it what went into actually
deciding okay i want to make the leap
yeah i was always terrified to make the
leap i didn't want to
i was kind of like that like i'm just
gonna
stay in austin and and be like
just do everything here and and [ __ ]
be in austin
kill it here but then uh so every year
there's this
uh contest funniest person in austin
contest
and i did that uh like three or four
years
i got third place twice thank you very
much
yeah never won never won
third place or second runner-up as i
like to say
um but but from doing the contest so
much
i i actually got uh jfl
one of the judges was a guy from jfl
and he was like come and be a new face
and so i went to jfl and i was a new
face and
and then uh from there i i got a manager
and now and she was like hey you should
come to la if you want to
kind of make bigger steps and i was like
no
i don't want to um but then she was like
no
and then everyone i have such a great
like family and friends and everyone's
like no you should go
so i went and and yeah
luckily knocked on wood things went well
yeah that's how i am here in atlanta is
i've been doing comedy
10 years and i i always had the mindset
i had friends that would move to la and
new york and just sleep on couches and
that but i was always like i would
rather do it
like you said from austin i want to do
it from atlanta i kind of want to build
build success here to show other comics
that they don't
have to move to get success
oh yeah i was totally on that train with
especially like atlanta and austin are
very like you know uh like up and coming
like
scenes and and like have bigger comedy
scenes like i've been atlanta and you
guys have a great comedy scene there
um and it's very similar to austin where
you're like i'm comfy here
you know i i got my shows i got the
people
i run with and like and also like big
names come here
and like you can open for them and
things so
and like there's a lot of people make
movies here and
there's opportunities here like for sure
so that's why i was like nah you don't
have to leave
um but i felt comfortable doing it when
i did it i was 32
and i i got a manager so i was like okay
fine and i i my boyfriend stayed in
austin so i kind of had the
safety net i was like don't come to
lakes if things don't work out
i could just come home yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah like you've been you've been
methodical
in your journey and just kind of because
you start well you you went to college
doing a theater and then sketch and
improv
and then you took you went into
stand-ups you've kind of almost done it
like kind of piece by piece
learning skill by skill yeah just a
little bit at a time because i i don't
know i i guess i
i've always wanted to do comedy since i
was little i never imagined
that i would do the things i've done and
have a comedy central special
like that still like boggles my mind
but i i've just been like the whole way
i've just been like i'm gonna do it
because it's fun and i i love it and
but i never expected anything i guess
you know
and the things just like kind of came
yeah starting starting comedy a lot of
people like
they want to do comedy but they're
scared maybe they're writing jokes
but they're scared to jump into comedy
and you were the same where there was
like a fear of like i can do sketch and
improv but stand-ups and other beasts so
like
what went into making that decision to
pursue it and like what advice do you
have for someone
on the fence about i want to do it but
oh yeah um i was totally scared i told
myself
i'll never do stand up that's terrifying
i need a group with me um but i started
doing
you know with sketch and improv like
keeping a group together it becomes so
hard
because everyone's doing 10 million
things people start getting married
having babies
so i was like okay i guess i'll do my
own thing and i started doing
solo sketch shows which was like i was
in character still like
i was still terrified to be vanessa on
stage
and but being a lo it kind of helped me
like do characters but be by myself
and then my friend lisa friedrich
actually
uh she's a comic here in austin and she
runs like so many stand-up shows
and she was like hey i'm going to book
you on one of my shows and you're just
going to do it
and i was like no and she's like yo
just five minutes she's like if you want
to get out in three that's fine like i
just think she like really just like
pushed me off the cliff oh that's great
do it and i was like but i don't know i
don't know how to write
jokes like you know i do characters i do
improv
and she's like just tell a story like
you got stories you're funny
and that's what i did i just told like
the story about my mom
and now all that's mainly like what i do
when i write jokes it's just all based
on real [ __ ]
that i've gone through so now i i think
like
of my jokes is just like little kind of
stories that i i make funny
i've i've approached it ever since yeah
that's what i admire about your comedy
what i enjoy
and if we were to use an example of one
uh like you're the underwear story
which everyone needs to go watch if
you're listening to this
later go like just search this on
youtube it's hilarious
and what i love is it is based in truth
it's based in reality it's a story that
has
beats and an arc but how
your your humor is based in truth which
we all strive for but how do you
actually like
have that experience he bought me
underwear well i don't want to give away
the joke but like how do you take it
from
this happened to now okay this needs to
be able to translate to stage which
there's a big misconnect there
yeah i mean so that really did happen
it was a traumatic thing
that upset me and i think
any time it's kind of like my therapy
right like this thing bothered me
and and then i just kind of take it like
piece by piece like
uh when i set it up which is kind of
like a problem now
because all of my jokes are like five to
ten minutes long
which is which is not ideal when you're
in la and they only give you four
minutes or whatever
um because i'll just like kind of start
it piece by piece i'll like set the
stakes you know especially if people
don't know who i am i'm like
okay so this is my first boyfriend this
is a big deal for me
i he bought me underwear you know and i
kind of just like lay it out so that
people know the backstory of like oh
this isn't just
any like guy buying a girl underwear
like this was a huge deal for me
and then yeah the underwear looked huge
when i took them out of the bag
and i was mortified and but then they
they fit
perfectly and
so kind of just kind of like uh i'll
start
by like testing it out and open mics
like just storytelling
and and i'll write down beats and but i
don't really know
where i'm gonna go if i'm trying to joke
out for the first time
and uh so i'll start a joke and it'll be
like 10 minutes long
and then i'll start like cutting it down
to where oh it feels just like
tight and it's just all punchy so do you
do you
write it all out and then or do you go
on stage and just try to
tell the story as it happened yeah i'll
just try to tear it
i'll i'll do like beats bullet points so
like this
i want to hit this that happened this
that happened and that that happened
yeah and i'll be like okay i know for
sure this is funny
and i know that uh though i have five
minutes
so to me i don't know if this happens
with everybody but i'm always like
i'll talk and i'm thinking like five
minutes
seems forever but i end up and then i
get the light i'm like damn it
i thought i had way more time yeah um
so i kind of like uh i'll definitely
take myself
listen to it over and over again and
then
once i like tried a couple times and
like
uh open mics then i'll start like
writing it down and trimming it i'm like
oh that didn't work
it's kind of like i'll solo improv by
myself this story
until i make something of it so i'll
just keep saying it keep
saying it and then kind of like
make it mold it into something as i go
when do you know when it's time to let
go of something
oh when i i'll do
it it sucks because like i'll think
things are hilarious
oh yeah and i'm like oh i gotta leave
this in
but i'll say it like four or five times
and no one laughs at
it and then my boyfriend will finally be
like yeah that's
not funny and i'm like it is
um so yeah i'll i'll try it um
a couple of times before i'm like fine
i'll finally get the hint
and i'm like nobody laughs at this part
so i'll cut it out
well sub comics do it for months you
know before they kill it so you're
realistic enough to be like four or five
times
all right let me just move on there's
more out there
yeah yeah you mentioned the underwear
story being traumatic
to you like when it happened you say it
was traumatic so how long did it take
you to actually
be like okay i'm ready to start talking
about this
uh well it's funny like i
like i remember it happened and then
like two days later
i had a show and i was like i'm gonna
i'm gonna talk about this
because one i was like i'm tired of my
old jokes
i don't wanna you know when you reach a
point where you're like i don't wanna
say these anymore
like yeah they're good you know they
they'll get you the little laughs but
you're like bored of them
so i'm like i don't want to say any of
these jokes i'm going to just talk about
this new thing
that happened so it's pretty like
immediate for me like if something
happens
i want to talk about it as soon as
possible because then
i still have that like it just happened
excitement
yeah and like i feel like it's so fun
for me when i have something like
you know i'm like y'all you're never
gonna believe this or you know something
happened or or something was said
and so i like to say it as soon as i can
after it happened and then a challenge
can be to replicate that excitement
the 210th 20th 30th 40th 50th how
how are you able to perform a joke that
may be old but perform it as if it's new
well that that's the hard part i think
that
um for me i
i get bored with jokes real fast
like i i think i i told this
one joke that was also traumatic
um and everyone like kept telling me
like do it again dude
i'm like it's not fun for me anymore but
it was it was kind of similar with the
underwear where
i went to a water park with my boyfriend
and they
they kept the ride kept yelling heaviest
rider must go in the back
and it was just like over and over again
like the heaviest rider must go in the
back
and i'm just looking at him like i'm not
going in the back sorry
you know um so there's this
whole joke about this water slide and i
said it for like
a year and then i was like i can't say
this anymore
it's done like i just had no more juice
behind it you ever
you ever feel that when you like got a
joke and like you're like it's good but
it's just like
i don't have the the juice that
it needs to be told anymore
but it's it's very interesting that
you're referencing
that experience was traumatic as well
like that's something
uh ron function ron function ron
functions
ron function he was uh he talked about
on here about how
he had a breakthrough in his comedy when
he started talking about things that
embarrassed him is that is that where
you're finding your best material is it
it has to be traumatic or it has to be
that would or otherwise be a secret that
i have to say on stage
yeah i think it's like fun and like
especially when things like that happen
instead of
dwelling on them of like oh i can't
believe it and like
kind of turning it into like self-hate
i'm like
making fun of it you know because i'm
like
in the end i'm not really letting it
bother me because i do see the humor in
it
so i'll like make fun of it and and make
light of it and kind of like helps me
not yeah turn it into like something
that
that i may like hate myself for
you know oh that's true yeah i guess it
could yeah it could
turn into resentment or fester i guess
it's good to get it out there and it
takes away the power of that trauma
yeah and it's like i realize when i talk
about like
traumatic things or embarrassing things
i think that's what people like relate
to more and latch on to
more like especially with when you're
trying to connect with the audience
there
i think that they're they're able to be
like
been there or like i i i would never
you know i would never talk about this
or they kind of like
connect with you more when you're when
you're going like
like pretty personal with stories but
it's so scary
like uncomfortable like you know i've
been doing it 10 years and i just
i just recently like recorded my first
special to get rid of
all that older material you know to then
force myself to be like okay
it's time you really start peeling back
the layers and
this all happened literally like i i
self-produced it did it all myself
released it in february
and then march happened and now we've
been in quarantine
so it's like it's like but it is peeling
back that onion is like
scary even for me doing it 10 years like
it's like it's
it's a it's a tough bridge to cross but
i'd imagine once you start it becomes
easier yeah i think
like i don't know i i think for me i've
just never been
good at the like set up punch line and
the people that are like really good at
that i'm like
so in of because my brain just doesn't
think that way i'm like my tweets are
like
you know but because i'm like let me
let me pull you in let me set it up let
me tell you a story let me
i i like to do act outs i like to you
know
be physical and that's like my thing
um but yeah i i feel like there's the
those two ways
of of doing stand-up but i i think both
are like
their own like craft you gotta you gotta
be good at you know and they both take
hard work
yeah it i i want to get more personal
but it is always
it always has been a a barrier and even
if i do
get personal i will hide behind a punch
line like
i'll hide behind cleverness as opposed
to being like no this is
this is what happened type deal so it is
just ripping the band-aid off um
yeah it's it's hard and then sometimes
like
people will like i don't know
i'm just trying to like be honest and
and talk my truth like i have this
a bit about how i'm not scared of my
parents anymore
and that's like really hit home with a
lot of people because
people are in their like 30s like me and
they're like oh god no i'm still
terrified
and i'm like [ __ ] them you know what are
they gonna do they can't do [ __ ] to us
wake up people you know and i was
telling this
joke of like early i think
it was like the just in january this
year and this woman walked out because
she was like you're so disrespectful
i can't believe you would say those
things about your parents and i'm like
what they're not here
you know i'm talking [ __ ] behind their
back
and also like yeah i'm still scared of
them
so i think it's like yeah i think
some some people are into it and other
people like
take it too in and and they're like
really
like oh you're being offensive or
they're like oh i'm so sorry that
happened to you
with underwear that's and i'm like oh
i'm
i'm making fun of it it's such a good
joke i mean you really will link it in
the show description as well
um but it's it's such a good story
um oh and we oh we got some people
popping in with questions here
as well um
so um this one actually comes from robin
sutton clark
asking um how much improv oh she waved
at you robin yeah they're watching live
right now this is great
and she asks how much improv goes into
stretching out a joke
and um how much is hack is it like can
you go too far with it
um i guess i mean i try
uh when i mean i'm like improvising a
joke i'm not i don't
try to get like too happy with it um
i i try to stay truthful to the story
and when i improvise it's in the like
embellishments or like if i'm
relating it to something you know like
it in the details is where
like i'll improv where you know like um
like in the in the underwear story i'm
like oh i
i pulled them out they did look huge but
you know in in the improv i'll like keep
unraveling
it to like make it be bigger and i'm
like it
you know i didn't know he thought i was
fitted
sheet size things like that like i'll
improv the details
but not too much of like i'm
you know honking my nose or you know
making making random [ __ ] up so
oh i love that improv in the details and
did that fitted sheet line come in
improv
where you were just kind of rattling off
ideas of how big it was
right yeah so it's like you're kind of
like
in the moment you're like finding
like things to compare it to and things
like that so yeah i feel like i i like
to improv the details and
and the embellishments and kind of like
i feel like it's like
coloring in like you have your like
outline of the story
and then you're just coloring it to make
it look prettier and funnier
i love that i absolutely love that
um this one tie this one ties in
to yeah really the writing process
as uh amanda oh asks uh what's your
writing process like and how do you
generate new material
um well yeah i feel like uh
like what we were talking about earlier
is like something will happen
and then i'll just bullet point it i
don't really like to write anything
out until i like try it out on stage and
i'll just be like i'm gonna i'm gonna
take a shot and just talk about this
thing that happened or this conversation
that i had
with my mom or this interaction i had at
the store is like
i'm gonna write it down this was kind of
like weird and
and funny you know so i'll i'll make
bullet points
and then i go to open mic or now zoom
show
and just kind of test it out and and
kind of figure out if i can like
find a path for it or build it out with
improv on stage
um and then sometimes it's like yeah
there's something there and they'll like
after the set i'll like write down like
oh that's good that sticks
but a lot of the times it's also like
wow i just talked for two minutes and
nothing so you switch
gears so it's all about like taking
risks like
trying it's like okay i'm gonna tell you
about this
thing that happened um and i think it's
it's particularly particularly
interesting now
with the zoom shows uh because
everyone's kind of going through the
same thing
so it's like how do we not all just have
a whole zoom show of
all of us talking about how shitty
everything is
you know trying to keep it like
personal to me and my experience i
i i'm like that's how i kind of like
uh not sound like
you know everyone else i'm like what did
what was my
personal experience on this or day or
something what about generating ideas
because writer's block can really
handicap a lot of us
like how do you overcome writer's block
well it's hard you know a lot of the
times um i don't really like
to write a joke unless i get that like
excited feeling in my stomach you know
like oh that was you know like the
underwear thing that happened or the
fight or
something um but whenever i can't
do anything i i had a friend well i have
a friend
uh his name's cj hunt we used to do uh
writing sprints together where we would
just kind of like
name a name a topic like random topic
and then put five minutes on the clock
or three minutes
and then we would just sit and write
down like premises
based on that topic and that was like
kind of helpful
just to kind of get the gears going and
sometimes you're like
okay we're going to talk about uh
you know i don't know one night stands
and then we write down
stuff that that made us think about for
five minutes
sometimes there's something there
sometimes there's not
um so yeah we would do exercise like
that but
i feel like lately i don't write
something unless i like get excited
about the thought
mm-hmm yeah in in this uh facebook group
we actually do a daily writing club
it's called the write 10 club and we uh
we
get a random word and then we spend 10
minutes
uh writing trying to write a joke about
it
oh yeah the same that's awesome
yeah that's awesome safe way great
yeah and i like you you start your jokes
from a place of like
this was traumatic or this was weird or
this was funny or this makes me excited
so you start with a connection
with the joke before you even take it to
the stage that's super valuable
yeah yeah like just things that came up
uh recently i wrote a joke that was
diagnosed with fatty liver recently
so i have this whole bit about my
experience going to the doctor
her telling me and and how i
you know wished i would have reacted
yeah so just like making things that i
experienced
but in like a funny or fun way with a
story
i love it and um well we got a
storytelling question as well
but michelle not to put you on the spot
but she asks if you would join us in the
right tin club
sometime oh sure that sounds fun
yeah that would be if you're in austin
you're central or is that
central yeah yeah that would be 9am but
there's comics in australia that tune in
and it's midnight where they are so
okay i mean midnight would work for me
more than that
i forgot we're comedians yeah yeah
comedians with no job but i don't
need to be up at night we're starting at
10 p.m one as well
okay we're gonna start yeah they're
getting so busy we're gonna start doing
like two a day
oh awesome well we will uh yeah we'll
we'll circle back on that
vanessa thank you uh and so june
asks um what do you think the biggest
mistake storytellers make
oh um mistake
i don't know i've seen like a lot of
different types of storytelling
and i feel like as long as you're
staying like
true to your like perspective and honest
like i think that's what like really
brings people in like i was saying with
that with the audience what connects
with the story
if you're being like vulnerable
i think you're on the right path but if
you're just kind of like
talking to you know i think
where i've made a mistake before is like
writing like with the intention of like
being funny writing a story where like
this is going to be hilarious
guilty but then but then it doesn't go
anywhere
you know but if i write a story first
with like a beginning middle and end
with like
just the actual like facts of what
happened
and then pepper in the jokes and color
it in like i said
then i have a a better story and it
feels like
fuller but i've i've told stories or
i've attempted to tell
or improv a story where i was like oh i
didn't have anything
going in and i was just like this
one little seed happened and then it
went nowhere
that's great yeah
oh and michelle said it is it's 9am
where she is as well
when she writes so oh no pressure
but van carey is in australia he's
watching right now and he said it's 5
40 a.m in australia right now and he's
watching
all right so i don't have an excuse then
that's fair oh boy
uh and um this this is a good one
here from joey rizzuto asking um
what were some worries you had starting
off what had to happen to overcome them
and do they ever come back
and do you have any new worries now
um i feel like what i loved about
starting off is like i didn't have
worries i felt like i
took way more risks because i was like i
don't give a [ __ ]
you know like i'm i'm starting at this
i'm new
and there was like less fear because i
was
new and then i think after
the special and now i have i get in my
head more of like
oh i have to live up to something
and i have to like everything has to be
as good as the pizza underwear story
and things like that so i feel like i
put more pressure on myself that i'm
trying to
like shake and and be like get back to
that place like i remember when i was
just starting an
improv and sketch where it would be the
dumbest idea
but i would totally just go for it and i
want to i want to get back in that zone
and i think that's what's like
the funniest now that's what makes me
laugh now when i watch
stand-up specials or any type of comedy
where it's like
the dumbest premise but and you're like
oh they're having so much fun i want i
want to
i wanted to do that i want to get back
to that place
but you were actually worried to even
try stand up
so how did you overcome that fear
well like i said my my friend lisa just
kind of threw me
oh so it was just back against the wall
okay yeah back against the wall
um but to be fair after i did that first
show
and it was okay i didn't die and
and it wasn't the worst i i just kept
you know
trying at it trying trying and i would
like i did
start start writing like uh
set up punchline type jokes and i
realized those
didn't work for me so then i just leaned
more into the storytelling
and and just kept kept going with that
little by
little and like tried to grow material
as i went but
it i feel like till this day stand up
is the one that gives me the most nerves
out of all of them you know doing improv
during sketch after while you're like
with your friends
like oh i don't care but every time you
do stand up you have that little like
here we go it could be good it could be
bad
and it's all on you yep because even you
kind of eased into it your first set was
you doing like a character
like a monologue almost of like your mom
so even you had to kind of like all
right
i gotta pull the just pull the bandit
off and start trying to do material type
deal
yeah and like talking as me and being
on it and and i think it was just like a
preference of like
i i i was like what kind of stand-up do
i like to watch
and i just like watching stand-ups that
that get vulnerable and and and
and say real [ __ ] and that just like hit
home with me
so i just leaned into that
yeah or def jam as well yeah yeah
i love jeff jam so good
what'd you like about it just like the
way the people would react like that's
still
that's still like a goal of mine to
have a deaf comedy jam moment where just
people are like
running out the room and you know
just dying on the floor in front of you
because what you just said was the
funniest [ __ ] they've ever heard
um and yeah and that's it like i feel
like death
the the comics on deaf comedy damn were
were
so like real and vulnerable and like
talking about real [ __ ] and that's why
like
everyone's like dying over it
yeah well
well to keep it real here or keep it one
honda
uh to keep it a bean yeah i mean
we have a special guest actually i want
to bring in here as we um
as we start to uh land this plane i want
to bring in a fan of yours
to um ask you a few questions
as well um okay so uh without further
ado
please welcome the reason we're all here
today
give it up for the one and only chris
grulin ladies and gentlemen
let's welcome him to the show here
let's see if he's uh
is he there oh wait hold on oh no
wait what happened wait there we are
sorry
i had to make sure the stream was just
me for a second we're here
i'm uh live from my son's bedroom
chris my man uh thank you first off for
even recommending vanessa and making
this happen um
yeah thank you so much that's so nice i
remember
watching you on that zoom show because
it was like 12 people
and you weren't laughing at anybody so i
was like
i was like i'm not gonna get him you
know what uh
it was so funny because uh you had that
one joke about being a snake charmer
um hilarious we were dying
uh yeah i play the flute to arouse my
boyfriend to keep it socially distant
thank you so what um
yeah please chris this is uh you you
have the floor my man
um whatever you'd like to ask as a
comedian watching
zoom shows i i start to analyze so i
don't laugh as much
what i don't know is that the comedians
are taking snapshots of me
and then throwing me into their jokes
yeah that was hilarious yeah um
so i did have a couple of questions um
how do you feel comedy is changing
during the pandemic do you think that
the zoom shows are something that's
going to stay
or are you more comfortable doing the
zoom shows
um i feel like uh
it it's so interesting because i've been
doing them pretty regularly and i'm like
nobody wants these right but every time
i do them like
people are [ __ ] like cooking and like
guided on in the background
people are sitting in their cars like
they're just like i gotta get away i'm
gonna watch this
show my car like i it's cool to see that
people still want
comedy even in this format so that's
like
that's nice i think though that people
will
like just like with anything like i'm
here in austin
everything's open like no but people
hear pandemic and they're like no i
still need to go to a bar and drink
um so i feel like they're the the way
they want
to be out and and pretend like
everything's fine
i think that comedy will always like
be wanted and needed um but
i don't know i wonder if even when like
there's
live shows again and like people are
doing them safe
oh sorry is that me um i wonder if
if zoom shows will still say a thing
because it's nice to be able to be like
hey i'm doing a show
in la with someone in new york and in
atlanta and
and it's like fine so i hope i've done
this shows with uh with everybody
uh from new york to australia so it's
been a great way to network
have you been able to expand your
network
because of the zoom shows um
yeah i i feel like uh it's been nice to
like i said to to do shows with like
comics from all the way around
from from all over and um yeah
especially um because before
what without this which is funny because
we could have been doing this the whole
time right
exactly but
yeah it's like oh i gotta get my ass to
new york and i gotta
i gotta go there for like two weeks do
the grind there so they kind of know who
i am
and i kind of like make my my name known
there
i gotta go atlanta so it's like all like
touring is
was the mindset before this um
so it's nice to have like this so that
you you kind of can make connections all
over without going anywhere
i like that i like that so uh you know
i'm right down the street from you
in new brunswick yeah yeah my brother
lives there
actually everything is open here and
it's kind of scary because we don't know
when the pandemic is going to end in
texas because
no one cares apparently right yeah
so now i'm going to be 38 this year
how um how
can i say a joke about my mom without
fearing her
well it's funny because uh my mom
is uh crazy and
um she she loves the jokes i tell about
her
like she's that like because she know
she's like kind of self-aware
and she knows she's ridiculous but i
think she's also a narcissist
so she loves like when i make fun of her
in the comedy central special i accuse
her of having an affair
and she had to sign a waiver saying that
she would not
sue me and she's like oh i don't care
this is hilarious oh [ __ ] which other
jokes are you gonna say
like so she's like she loves it she
likes the attention it i think she likes
to come to my
shows and then i make fun of her and
after the shows she's always like
hi i'm the mom and she's like taking
pictures with people
she loves it it's so funny because i
i've been doing a joke a day now i don't
know for like 45 days
as my daughter walks in in the
background
i hope you see her yeah
i saw the door open and i was like is
this the ring what just happened
[Music]
i've been throwing jokes out for about
45 days and a lot of them have to do
with my mom and i got a text message the
other day saying
real quick do you have any jokes about
your wife
[Laughter]
oh well yeah i don't know uh about
wife jokes because when i make fun of my
boyfriend
or what i don't i never make fun of my
boyfriend he's always
in the jokes but he's never the butt of
the joke
which which i always try to stay mindful
of and he's totally fine he's like
as long as you're not like making fun of
me you could say whatever
and uh i'm i always make it a point that
i'm the butt of the joke
yeah me me too with my wife material and
uh nate bargatsu said the same thing on
here
about if he ever made a joke about his
wife
it people didn't like it as much as if
it was he was the butt of the joke so
that's always a good
little cheat to make jokes about it
without it being
about it type deal yeah like things that
happen
situations conversations i mean
naturally are funny right in
relationships
um but people love when my mom's the
better the joke
i think everyone's like i got something
with their moms
all right is there anything else chris
um one more
uh the special that you recorded um
my birthday's tomorrow oh yeah i am
hilarious
about calling your parents and telling
them to go screw themselves
yeah um i did have a question
about adapting to the zoom culture
because so many established comics
feel that uh this is hack
and they don't want to do zoom culture
but then when they
do go on a mic live they're rusty do you
feel that these zoom shows
are helping you stay sharp oh absolutely
and that's really why i'm doing them you
know i i do
see that like a lot of comics are like
[ __ ] on them and but i think that's
like
part of it and i think what i've always
uh tried not to like get my whole
head around is is the whole negative
like
talking because i i you know here in
austin it's like a very supportive
community you go to la it's
also i was very surprised like how
supportive
of the comedy community in la was too
but you're gonna get
like comics of [ __ ] talk or that tack
and all this stuff
and but what i i feel like
it's like i don't know it's like a
personal growth thing but i
started being hard on myself when i
stopped judging and [ __ ] on other
comics
like when i was just like open and like
supportive
and like you know it's like yeah maybe
it's not my thing but i'm not gonna [ __ ]
talk anybody like they're trying
something
and that's that's cool you know and i
think that's like
i don't know why it became this whole
thing as a
comic you got to be like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and that [ __ ] it's like what we're
all trying to just make people laugh
why are we [ __ ] on each other yes
you know
one of the things that i really enjoyed
about the zoom comedy
is that you can get a a night where you
can have four headliners on one show
and you would never see that in a comedy
club and then yeah
on top of that some of them do q and a's
afterwards
and you're only paying like 10 which is
insane to me
yeah i did want to plug in our show
september 19th
yeah we'll be doing a show together what
yep i'm producing a show
what yep oh my gosh that's so
awesome yeah and it's because of of
this right ten group um so
i'm producing a show vanessa's
headlining and i have
uh oh i'm i have gonna cry
oakland l.a and laredo on it hell yeah
i'm from laredo i know i know yeah
that's so cool man yeah oh number 19.
i just that's awesome i just love and i
well i want to love
like your mindset behind comedy vanessa
in terms of well first you did want to
just develop and get good and develop in
your own city and create your own
success and then also it is like
yeah we're all ever what what's the hate
for we're
everyone we're all trying to just make
people laugh like there's no need to
have negativity around
this really fun art form and it's just
they're doing something that's great for
them you know
yeah and i think like like i said i i've
always just
loved doing comedy and i've always just
kind of like
made an agreement with myself like hey
this is the thing i love i'm always
gonna have to
do it myself somehow whether it's
producing my own shows or getting out
there
and then but i never like expected
anything and it's like
okay yeah the things come which is nice
but i still believe that
as as i get older i'm always going to
have to make
[ __ ] myself record my own albums i have
to you know record my own special like
you don't have to wait
for you know that you can make [ __ ]
happen you can produce your own shows
and like be a nice person and not [ __ ]
on anyone while you do it
and that's what's been hard is is
becoming a new comic in the area um
because i'm
i i'm in the san antonio group
um and um trying not to get sucked into
the politics of it
while still growing that's my son
yeah trying to still grow as a comic
and not burn any bridges with anybody in
the scene
and while everybody's choosing sides
it's really hard
yeah it's it's interesting when there's
like you know i think every
comedy scene has its own dramas
and like clicks and stuff but it's you
know i think
you gotta not get tucked into that and
and just stay
you know focused on you and your writing
and
and just being like nice and open i
think
my one of my friends uh lashonda lester
um she passed away a couple years ago
she was great comic and she always told
me like all you have to do is be funny
and be nice
that's all you got to do
the best advice i've been given was
worry about your set
and uh their opinions don't pay your
bills because when you get on stage
it's only you and the mic yeah and it's
like
and even like when you go to open mics
or zoom shows you know i like to watch
and i like to laugh at the other comics
like
you can't go up you can't watch a whole
show
like this and being just like judging
and shitty
and then you expect to go up there and
get laughs when you didn't give
any love or you know support and it's
like
then circling back to your zoom show i
apologize if i didn't
[Music]
with the call back on him with a call
back
no but one thing i learned was the uh
the hot comedy festival was here in san
antonio
i am premiering on hbo max tonight
but one thing i saw was the veteran
comedians sitting in the back
watching all the new people and then
when the new people were done
they would give them a napkin or a
notepad saying hey try this
on your joke try it adding this and i've
never seen that before
and it opened me up to say uh
we're here to help each other grow you
know what i mean so it was
really really cool to see and i really
appreciate you even doing the zoom show
with me
yeah i don't know why it's been a
culture of like we can't help each other
we're all like in a race against each
other
but it's like no we should like why not
take a tag or
you know if we we all have that comedy
brain and sometimes some comics see
something others don't
and you know i'm all about it and i
think it's just
like it makes your life better when
you're just like
not being negative the first year i was
walking in not knowing
if i was funny enough or uh
am i doing this as a hobby
am i gonna take this more serious and
then i entered the
um funniest comedian in texas and i got
into the semi-finals in my first year
nice so then it it made me think okay i
do have something here
let me keep growing this and so that's
why i joined the ride tent club it's
been really helpful
yeah yeah that's so awesome that you all
do that that's so
so cool and i love that it just
reinforces that whole like
we're friends helping each other yeah
one guy
bob he's kind of uh he thinks he's too
funny
yeah well you're always gonna have that
that's the whole thing with the group
though is like
we have core values and it's like
positivity
community and productivity so it's all
about community and
positivity but also hey we're here to
get better at comedy
but everything's positive everything's
positive because i learned from personal
experience
and doing this for 10 years i'm sure you
know you've expressed the same of yeah
there's negativity and there doesn't
need to be
yeah i think it's silly especially now
like
especially now with like comics [ __ ]
on zoom shows it's like why
we're all it's a [ __ ] pandemic
like why are we everyone's just trying
to figure out what works for them you
know
like uh how can you stand by the moral
of like nah
i'm clubs only right they're all
because with these doom shows i was able
to network with mikey winfield
and frankie marcos and i was able
to get all these people to talk to me to
the point where mikey
sent me an email wanting an input on one
of his flyers
i started promoting for him that brought
me to renee
that brought me to you and it's opened
up my network
and it would have never happened without
this pandemic yeah
yeah i i think if you embrace it it
can't i think what that goes with
anything
like you can make stuff work with you
work for you you know
i love this when i heard you guys are
doing a show together i almost cried i
was like oh my gosh
the hot breath the verse at work
number 19 i love it number 19. well
we'll be sure to put a link in the show
description also
to um if you have a like a registration
for that
show or whatever chris i'll definitely
share it i'm working on the event
uh page tonight and the flyer should be
out tonight perfect and we'll get a link
we'll do a link to your um
your album as well um i didn't see that
on your website i don't think
oh yeah uh i i told my little brother to
update it and he hasn't
okay because i was like wait what
because i always research my guest and i
want to make sure
um yeah cause i didn't know that yeah i
have an
album uh it's called my birthday's
tomorrow
these are pins that i'm also selling
um oh yeah that's the cover of the album
too
uh but yeah check it out i recorded it
last year
uh in october you're in austin
did you do it uh through uh it looks
like the label was ast
or something like that yeah a special
thing okay
so you did it through a record company
that's something we talked about with
sarah tolemosh
last week because she went through a
record company as well and we were like
weighing the pros and cons of each route
yeah i feel like it was definitely
beneficial for me
because i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
doing with it with
with recording [ __ ] so
it was nice that someone was like hey
we'll do that all for you you just go
and tell your jokes i'm like perfect
well we'll put links to that and i
definitely want to buy one of those pins
so i'll um
oh yeah yeah i definitely want to show
support and uh the the last question we
always ask here is like your favorite
most helpful comedy advice you've ever
received or something you could kind of
leave us comics with here
well definitely um what my friend
lashonda lester told me was
you know just be funny and be nice and
um i think
the best advice that i've heard from
anyone is just
always have fun with it when it's you
know when you're being too serious or
it's matter it becomes about grudges and
and [ __ ] talking and negativity it's
like you're not doing it
for the right reasons you're you're
there to make people laugh
so always have fun with whatever you're
talking about
oh my gosh i love it this has been
amazing um
you're yeah you're you definitely
express like the same
intentions with comedy that we do here
at hot breath so it's been a thrill to
have you on here yeah
this was so fun thank you so much for
having me awesome absolutely so go forth
uh yeah
support vanessa so and uh pick up her
album pick up a pin
like i'm doing and um also support their
show that
they're doing together on september 19th
that's very exciting
yeah thumbs up thank you everyone for
watching here
live in the facebook group as well and
if you guys want to
watch this later it'll be on our youtube
it'll also be posted on our podcast as
well wherever you listen to your
podcasts
but that's it for our q a with the one
and only vanessa gonzalez everyone give
a round of applause
thank y'all and uh we will see y'all
next time hopper at the verse
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these
every single day and watch this playlist
of our top writing tips to improve your
writing
today